here with reaction outnumbered co-host
kaylee mcinerney along with fox news
contributor douglas murray kaylee start
with you
why
is there this imperative on the left
to
to we're talking about kids from
kindergarten first second and third
grade to talk about transgenderism and
sexuality at all especially because we
spent more money per student with the
worst results in reading writing math
science and computers why don't we focus
on the basics
exactly sean the left has a sick
obsession with their children just today
think about the last 24 hours
of for the white house they want to
force face cloth coverings on
two-year-olds on airplanes and force
teach them about sexuality and gender
ideology at kindergarten i mean when my
daughter goes to school i don't want her
learning about those things coming home
and teaching being taught things that i
then have to explain to her and of all
the issues to cry and get upset about
sean there's a war in ukraine there is
bloodshed in our streets children
literally dying on the streets from
crime that is totally out of control and
rampant there is covid where more
americans have died on joe biden's watch
than on president trump's there is a lot
to cry about namely if you want to cry
about one issue in this country right
now i think the press secretary should
cry about the 62 million children that
do not exist that have been aborted
because of roe v wade a heinous heinous
decision in this country that has
exterminated about one-fifth of the
united states population so if you want
to cry don't cry about forcing sexuality
on kindergartners that is sick cry about
the 62 million children who can't even
go to kindergarten you know as i look at
this bill um
you know this the state of florida
reacted
and you know it's troubling that the
biden administration would break down in
tears because of a law that protects
parental rights so douglas it may shock
some people in school systems but there
are many parents out there that have
values that are very different than the
school and very different than what a
teacher might be teaching their kids who
has the right to instill values are we
going to hand our kids over to the
schools
they get to instill the values or the
parents get to instill the values i vote
for the parents absolutely every time
you know jen saki i think is just
making sure that her signing cure at
msnbc is absolutely safe
this sort of mixture of
sentimentality and fake emotion is
something that we know we've seen for
years from rachel maddow and others
breaking down in tears that ridiculous
and insignificant things and this is
ridiculous and insignificant it's
ridiculous because she's crying about as
you've just pointed out sean something
that isn't happening
the ridiculous thing on top of all of
that is that as we all know uh here
the the whole bill in florida has
nothing to do with persecuting gay
people anything like it it's about
trying to stop not just the imposition
of of teaching about sex to
kindergarteners but stopping the
teaching of an ideology that was
literally invented about 18 months ago i
mean you know two months two years ago
nobody had heard about any of the gender
fluid nonsense nobody talked about
non-binaryism everybody knew until
yesterday that there were two sexes and
that some people were attracted to their
own sex uh now we've got this new
ideology which disney and others have
decided to force on the american people
or decide is an amazing and ancient
right to understand that there are about
a hundred genders actually it's so
important to understand that they don't
know how many genders there are yet
because they're making it up as they go
along it's incredibly dangerous what
these people are doing
my favorite was the first graders being
taught now when doctors deliver babies
they're really just guessing if it's a
boy or a girl they're telling first
graders that they're just
it's an educated guess by the it's not a
guess
anyway um and nobody supports
discrimination most americans are
libertarian live your own life but leave
the kids alone let the parents deal with
these issues and if they want to have
after-school opt-in programs they can do
that all right kaylee thank you douglas
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else